first on cbs this morning a new lawsuit
accuses the company
behind one of the world's most popular
pornography websites of running
a criminal enterprise pornhub markets
itself as a mainstream site for adult
content attracting
130 million users a day which by the way
is reportedly more
than netflix or amazon but cbs news has
learned more than 30 women are now suing
pornhub's parent company
mind geek they accuse it of exploiting
them for profit
hosting and promoting graphic videos of
rape
revenge even child porn all in an effort
to drive up revenue
only on cbs news we spoke with some of
the women who are joining the lawsuit
we've changed their names to protect
their identities and we should warn you
some of this report includes graphic
language
i was making really good grades i had
friends i was in clubs
i thought i was set up really nicely at
the college i was at
isabella agreed to speak with us only on
the condition that she'd be able to wear
a disguise as she described in often
painful detail
how a private nude video she had shared
years ago with a high school boyfriend
became public when it was posted to
pornhub
the video got sent to me and immediately
i knew it was me i mean
my face my outfit um
immediately that's gotta be shocking
my heart dropped into my stomach
she says she was just 17 when she shot
it and thinks her boyfriend
sent it to someone else who posted it
anonymously
is there any possibility that pornhub
tried to contact you
to confirm your age no they did not to
confirm that it was consensual they did
not
they didn't they did not how many people
saw it over 200 000
200 000 people including everybody at my
college pretty much
um just knowing that that many people
saw it really messed me up what is that
feeling
shame and guilt
because i feel like i did it to myself
even though you know you didn't
it's taken me a long time to come to
terms with the fact that i am a victim
of something
and she's now trying to protect other
potential victims by telling her story
and suing pornhub's parent company mind
geek
the lawsuit on behalf of more than 30
women accuses the company of embracing
underage non-consensual and pirated
content
to drive traffic to the dozens of porn
sites it owns
and claims it profited from content
produced through
human trafficking lawyer michael bowie
represents the women
taking on mind geek he says the company
skirted the rules of the traditional
porn industry
by allowing anybody to upload videos
without first verifying age
or identities the law prohibits
what they're doing the law has not been
enforced he spent the past year building
a civil case against the company
citing racketeering laws ordinarily
reserved for mobsters and drug gangs
their image that they try to project is
that they are a friendlier cleaner
part of the porn industry what's the
reality
the reality is that that is a front this
is an organization that deals with
legitimate porn
of which there is a you can make a
fortune
but that wasn't enough they incorporated
into that business
child porn traffic porn rape videos
to make money nearly half the women in
the lawsuit say they were underage in
videos uploaded to pornhub
another woman who appeared in a video
tagged sleeping pills
told us she was drugged and raped by her
ex-husband
who filmed the assault and uploaded it
to pornhub
and then there's aubrey i will never
ever be able to recover
the emotional pain that this has caused
me her ex-husband faces criminal charges
for secretly recording a video of them
having sex
and posting it to pornhub without her
consent
everybody had seen everything about me
and that's just
it's a very private moment and it's a
very
vulnerable moment and it's just
it's hard to come to terms with that the
world has seen that
yet people continued to see it even
after aubry contacted pornhub to remove
the video
emails reviewed by cbs news show a
company representative
challenged her asking how do you know
this is you
i told them that it's me and i'm mad
that it's up there and that
i recognize myself i recognize my bed
it's it's me and they need to take it
down immediately
and did they no the process took
days but even after pornhub took down
the video
she says copies popped up on other porn
sites
i'd find it re-uploaded with a different
name
just by other people yes it would
constantly show up on these websites
when did you leave the company and why
did you leave the company we spoke over
the phone with a former company
executive who provided information
included in the lawsuit
he says illegal content was viewed as
being good for business
he disguised his voice to protect his
identity how
would mindgeek the company benefit from
illegal content on the site i mean if
you offer everything on the site there
is something for everyone
the more you have the better it is so
for all the free sites like pornhub more
content is always better
he said when content was flagged on
pornhub mindgeek often moved it to other
sites it owned
they removed content but removed content
again and again
and no one really cared mindgeek
announced changes last december
removing millions of unverified videos
banning downloads and adding an id
requirement for people posting videos
changes company executives addressed
earlier this year in a government
hearing
in canada sexual material and child
abuse material
has no place on our platform it makes us
lose money
it completely ruins the brand that we
have been trying to build for over a
decade
if you could address the ceos the
executives
at pornhub and tell them what this
experience is like
from this side what would you tell them
how would they like it if it was someone
they loved
their their child their um
you know their sister they've got to
take steps to prevent this from ever
happening to anybody ever again
so mind geek executives declined our
request for an
interview but in a statement to cbs news
the company said
any suggestion that the company
tolerates illegal content
is patently false adding that it has
enacted the most comprehensive
safeguards in user-generated history
mind geek also began reporting cases of
suspected child abuse material
to the national center for missing and
exploited children they started doing
this for the first time just last year
and it made 13 000 of those reports but
the center says that victims and
survivors continue to express
frustration with mind geek's record in
removing
abusive content finally and this is key
the company still does not confirm the
consent
of everyone who appears in the videos
posted to the site
that's the critical point it seems to me
it's like i mean if you have a video
that's suspect
at all i mean how do you know that the
people who are involved in it
agree to it being there very good
question and mind geek only made these
changes
after a big nick kristoff op-ed in
december
yeah uh and the the remaining question
is
whether the laws that currently govern
the traditional videotape and dvd porn
industry will be
passed by congress and made to apply to
these hosting sites
like pornhub it's just so outrageous
it is so hurtful these poor women are
gonna
hopefully not but many of them will live
with this for the rest of their lives
and you know when
when one of the the women said i i feel
shame and guilt like i brought this on
to myself i thought it was so important
that you said but you didn't
you know that right you know it's it's
one thing to know that intellectually
but to really feel that inside
you know this this is so damaging i'm so
glad you did this story what i walk away
haunted by
is something aubrey told me uh which is
when she found her video that her
ex-husband had uploaded
there were many other women there on the
site as well that he had filmed
yeah so there are a lot of women out
there who don't know to this day that
they were there for years and may still
be
this is just the tip of the iceberg